أهلاً بكم مجدداً في سلسلة فهم المعلومات والحوسبة الكمية، اسمي John Watrous وأنا المدير
التقني للتعليم في IBM Quantum. هذا هو الدرس الحادي عشر في السلسلة والدرس الثالث في
الوحدة الثالثة التي تتناول الصياغة العامة للمعلومات الكمية. هذا الدرس عن القياسات التي تمثل
واجهة بين المعلومات الكمية والكلاسيكية. عندما يُجرى قياس على نظام وهو في
حالة كمية، تُستخرج معلومات كلاسيكية تكشف شيئاً عن تلك الحالة الكمية وعادةً ما تغيّر أو
تدمر تلك الحالة في العملية. في الصياغة المبسطة للمعلومات الكمية التي نوقشت
في الوحدة الأولى من السلسلة، عادةً ما نقصر اهتمامنا على القياسات الإسقاطية بما في ذلك
أبسط نوع من القياسات وهو قياسات الأساس المعياري. لكن من الممكن تعميم مفهوم القياس
وهذا يتبين أنه شيء مفيد جداً. في هذا الدرس سنتحدث عن القياسات بشكل عام تماماً
بما في ذلك كيفية وصفها بالمصطلحات الرياضية وكيف تتناسب مع الصياغة العامة للمعلومات
الكمية. قرب نهاية الدرس سنلقي نظرة أيضاً على مفهومين أساسيين مرتبطين بالقياسات وهما تمييز الحالة الكمية
وتصوير الحالة الكمية المقطعي. فلنبدأ. هذه نظرة عامة على
الدرس. كعادتنا سنبدأ بالأساسيات بما في ذلك طريقتين مختلفتين لكن متكافئتين يمكننا من خلالهما
وصف القياسات بالمصطلحات الرياضية. بشكل خاص يمكننا وصف القياسات بمجموعات من المصفوفات
ويمكننا أيضاً وصفها كقنوات وهو ما أشرت إليه في الدرس السابق. سنناقش أيضاً القياسات
الجزئية أو بمعنى آخر القياسات التي تُجرى على جزء واحد فقط من نظام مركب
أكبر. ثم سننتقل إلى نظرية Naimark وهي حقيقة أساسية تتعلق بالقياسات تقول بشكل أساسي
أن القياسات العامة يمكن تنفيذها دائماً بطريقة بسيطة تذكّر بتمثيلات Stinespring
للقنوات. باختصار القياسات العامة يمكن تنفيذها دائماً عن طريق إدخال
نظام عمل مهيأ أولاً ثم إجراء عملية وحدوية وأخيراً إجراء قياس أساس معياري
على نظام العمل. هذا يتبين أنه سهل الإثبات وسنرى كيف يسير ذلك
وسنرى أيضاً كيف يرتبط هذا بما يُسمى القياسات غير المدمرة التي سأصفها. أخيراً في الجزء الأخير من
الدرس سنناقش تمييز الحالة الكمية وتصوير الحالة الكمية المقطعي. سنبدأ بالأوصاف الرياضية
للقياسات. القياسات توفر لنا واجهة بين المعلومات الكمية
والكلاسيكية. عندما يُجرى قياس على نظام وهو في حالة كمية ما، تُستخرج معلومات كلاسيكية
عن تلك الحالة الكمية. بالإضافة إلى ذلك تتغير الحالة الكمية عادةً أو ربما تُدمر
بالكامل. في البداية سنركز اهتمامنا على ما يُسمى القياسات المدمرة حيث
تدخل حالة كمية وتخرج فقط معلومات كلاسيكية فلا يوجد تحديد
للحالة الكمية بعد القياس للنظام الذي قيس. بشكل حدسي يمكننا تخيل أن القياس المدمر
يدمر أي نظام تم قياسه فحالته بعد إجراء القياس لا تكون
محددة. هذا لا يعني حرفياً أن الأجهزة الفيزيائية تُدمر بالضرورة، إنه مجرد وصف رياضي
وهو مفيد جداً لأنه يساعد على إبقاء الأمور بسيطة والتركيز على الجوانب
الرياضية الأساسية للقياسات. هناك بشكل خاص طريقتان متكافئتان لوصف القياسات
المدمرة والتي ذكرتها خلال النظرة العامة على الدرس. إحدى الطرق لوصف قياس
مدمر هي بمجموعة من المصفوفات حيث يكون لدينا بشكل خاص مصفوفة واحدة لكل نتيجة قياس
ممكنة. الطريقة الثانية لوصف قياس مدمر هي بقناة حيث
المدخل هو حالة أي نظام يُقاس والمخرج هو دائماً مصفوفة كثافة قطرية يمكننا
تفسيرها كوصف لتوزيع احتمالي على نتائج القياس الكلاسيكية
الممكنة. الوصفان متكافئان وهذا مفيد جداً لأنه يسمح لنا باختيار أي وصف يكون أكثر ملاءمة في
موقف معين. سنتحدث أيضاً عن القياسات غير المدمرة حيث بالإضافة إلى نتيجة القياس الكلاسيكية
تكون الحالة الكمية بعد القياس للنظام الذي قيس أيضاً
محددة. القياسات غير المدمرة مهمة وتظهر بشكل متكرر لكن هناك معنى تكون فيه
بطريقة ما ليست أساسية بقدر القياسات المدمرة من الناحية الرياضية. بشكل خاص كما يتبين
يمكن دائماً وصف القياسات غير المدمرة كتركيبات من القنوات والقياسات المدمرة و
سنرى كيف يعمل ذلك لاحقاً في الدرس. الآن لنلقِ نظرة على كيفية وصف القياسات أي القياسات
المدمرة كمجموعات من المصفوفات. خلال هذا النقاش سنفترض أن X هو نظام
يُقاس ومن أجل التبسيط سنضع بعض الافتراضات. أولاً سنفترض أن
مجموعة الحالات الكلاسيكية لـ X تتكون من الأعداد الصحيحة من 0 إلى n ناقص واحد لعدد صحيح موجب n والنتائج الممكنة
للقياس هي الأعداد الصحيحة من 0 إلى M ناقص واحد أيضاً لعدد صحيح موجب M. لا يحتاج
أن تكون هناك أي علاقة بين العددين n و M فهما عددان صحيحان موجبان عشوائيان وبالطبع يمكننا استبدال
هذه المجموعات بمجموعات حالات كلاسيكية عشوائية إذا أردنا ذلك. أولاً لنتذكر كيف تعمل القياسات
الإسقاطية والتي تحدثنا عنها أول مرة في الدرس الثالث من السلسلة. بالنظر إلى أننا نفترض أن
نتائج القياس هي الأعداد الصحيحة من 0 إلى n ناقص واحد نصف قياساً إسقاطياً بمجموعة
من الإسقاطات Pi 0 إلى Pi M ناقص واحد التي مجموعها يساوي مصفوفة الوحدة وهذه المصفوفات جميعها لها صفوف
وأعمدة تتوافق مع الحالات الكلاسيكية لـ X أو بعبارة أخرى هذه جميعها مصفوفات n في
n. إذا كان X في حالة كمية موصوفة بمتجه حالة كمية s فكل نتيجة قياس ممكنة
a تظهر باحتمال يساوي مربع النظيم الإقليدي لـ Pi a مضروباً
في المتجه s. مربع النظيم الإقليدي لأي متجه يساوي الجداء الداخلي لذلك
المتجه مع نفسه فنحصل على التعبير الموضح على الشاشة ويمكننا تبسيط ذلك قليلاً
باستخدام حقيقة أن Pi a هو إسقاط فضربه في نفسه لا يغير
شيئاً. وأخيراً يمكننا إعادة كتابة التعبير الذي حصلنا عليه بطريقة مختلفة قليلاً باستخدام الخاصية الدورية
للأثر مرة أخرى كما هو موضح على الشاشة. وإذا لم يكن واضحاً لماذا نريد كتابة التعبير بهذا الشكل فالإجابة
المختصرة هي أننا نريد فهم كيف تعمل القياسات الإسقاطية لمصفوفات
الكثافة. وبشكل خاص بالخطية نحصل على أنه إذا كانت حالة X موصوفة بمصفوفة كثافة rho بدلاً
من متجه حالة كمية s فإن احتمال ظهور النتيجة a يُعطى بأثر الإسقاط
Pi a مضروباً في مصفوفة الكثافة rho. وهذا لا بد أن يكون صحيحاً لأنه كما رأينا
يمكننا دائماً التفكير في مصفوفة الكثافة كمتوسط موزون للحالات النقية وإذا حسبنا متوسط
الاحتمالات المقابلة نحصل على هذا التعبير لأن الأثر دالة خطية. فهذا هو التعبير الذي
نسعى إليه ويمكننا ترتيب الأمور قليلاً للتركيز على مصفوفات
الكثافة. والهدف الأساسي من القيام بهذا بالمناسبة هو تحديد نقطة مرجعية لما تعلمناه سابقاً
ولنرى أن هذا الوصف للقياسات الإسقاطية هو في الحقيقة حالة خاصة من وصف أعم للقياسات سنراه
الآن. فما سأفعله هو استبدال هذا الوصف لكيفية عمل القياسات الإسقاطية لمصفوفات الكثافة
بالوصف للقياسات العامة حتى نفهم العلاقة. وها هو
ذا: القياس العام وليس بالضرورة إسقاطياً يُوصف بمجموعة من المصفوفات شبه الموجبة
المحددة P0 إلى PM ناقص واحد التي مجموعها يساوي مصفوفة الوحدة. وإذا أُجري هذا القياس على X وهو
في حالة موصوفة بمصفوفة كثافة rho فإن كل نتيجة a تظهر باحتمال يساوي أثر PA ضرب
rho. باختصار الشيء الوحيد الذي تغير هو أننا خففنا الشرط على هذه المصفوفات. بشكل خاص المصفوفات
لا تحتاج أن تكون مصفوفات إسقاط بل فقط شبه موجبة المحددة وتبعاً لذلك استبدلت الحرف Pi بالحرف P
لأن Pi اسم تقليدي للإسقاط بينما أفضل استخدام الحرف P للمصفوفات شبه الموجبة
المحددة. هذا تعميم للوصف الذي كان لدينا للقياسات الإسقاطية بالمناسبة لأن مصفوفات الإسقاط دائماً شبه موجبة
المحددة وفي الحقيقة يمكن تعريفها بديلاً كمصفوفات شبه موجبة المحددة قيمها الذاتية
لا يمكن أن تكون إلا صفراً وواحداً. يمكننا ملاحظة أن هذا التعريف
منطقي بمعنى أننا نحصل دائماً على متجه احتمالي لاحتمالات النتائج بالطريقة
التالية. أولاً هذه الأرقام التي أسميتها احتمالات النتائج هي دائماً أعداد حقيقية غير سالبة وذلك
لأن كلاً من PA و rho شبه موجبة المحددة وأثر جداء مصفوفتين شبه موجبتي
التحديد هو دائماً عدد حقيقي غير سالب وسأترك لكم التفكير في سبب
ذلك. وثانياً الأرقام يجب أن يكون مجموعها واحداً لأن الأثر خطي و
المصفوفات P0 إلى PN ناقص واحد مطلوب أن يكون مجموعها مصفوفة الوحدة ومصفوفات الكثافة أثرها يساوي
واحداً. فبغض النظر عن مصفوفة الكثافة rho التي بدأنا بها ستشكل احتمالات النتائج دائماً
متجه احتمالي. الآن لنلقِ نظرة على بعض الأمثلة. ذكرت سابقاً أن
القياسات الإسقاطية هي حالة خاصة من القياسات العامة لأن الإسقاطات دائماً شبه موجبة المحددة
لكن من الجميل أن نبدأ ببساطة فلنبدأ بقياس أساس معياري لـ qubit. يمكننا تمثيل قياس أساس معياري
لـ qubit بمصفوفتين P0 و P1 معرفتين كما هو موضح على الشاشة. P0 هي ket صفر bra صفر و P1 هي ket واحد
bra واحد. هاتان مصفوفتان شبه موجبتا التحديد وهما في الواقع إسقاطات ومجموعهما بوضوح يساوي
مصفوفة الوحدة فمعاً تصفان قياساً. إذا طبقنا هذا القياس على qubit
في حالة موصوفة بمصفوفة كثافة rho فاحتمال ظهور النتيجة صفر هو أثر P0 ضرب rho
واحتمال ظهور النتيجة واحد هو أثر P1 ضرب rho وبالخاصية الدورية للأثر نحصل على
العنصرين القطريين لـ rho كما نتوقع. هنا مثال آخر حيث
المصفوفات هذه المرة ليست إسقاطات. هي شبه موجبة المحددة وتصادف أنها مصفوفات
كثافة لكن هذا ليس مهماً. المهم هو أن مجموعها يساوي مصفوفة الوحدة فمعاً تصفان
قياساً. يمكننا رؤية ما يحدث عند إجراء هذا القياس على qubit في حالة plus مثلاً لنرى
كيف يعمل لمثال واحد على حالة وحساب الاحتمالات موضح على
الشاشة. لاحظ بشكل خاص أنه رغم أن حالة plus هي حالة نقية ويمكننا تمثيلها بمتجه الحالة الكمية ket plus إلا أنه يجب
أن نضع تمثيل مصفوفة الكثافة لتلك الحالة وهو ket plus bra plus في الصيغ للحصول على
الاحتمالات. ودعوني أشير أيضاً إلى أنه بما أننا نتحدث عن قياس مدمر فلا يوجد أي
تحديد للحالة الكمية بعد القياس لهذا الـ qubit. فكل ما لدينا هو تحديد لاحتمالات
النتائج. هنا مثال أخير في الوقت الحالي وهو مثير للاهتمام. مرة أخرى هو قياس لـ
qubit واحد ولوصفه سنبدأ بتعريف أربعة متجهات حالة كمية تُعرف بالحالات رباعية
الأوجه. وسبب تسميتها بالحالات رباعية الأوجه هو أنها تتوافق مع الرؤوس الأربعة
لرباعي أوجه منتظم مُدرج داخل كرة Bloch. وللتوضيح عندما نقول رباعي أوجه منتظم
نعني مجسماً رباعي الأوجه كل وجه منه مثلث متساوي الأضلاع. فهناك تناظر مثالي حيث كل
حافة لها نفس الطول ونفس الزاوية تتشكل بين أي حافتين
متجاورتين. والآن يمكننا تعريف قياس مثير بأربع نتائج ممكنة كما هو موضح على الشاشة. أو بالكلمات يمكننا أخذ
مصفوفاتنا لتكون تمثيلات مصفوفة الكثافة لهذه الحالات مقسومة على اثنين. هذه بالتأكيد مصفوفات شبه موجبة
المحددة لأنها مصفوفات كثافة مقسومة على اثنين ويمكنك إجراء الحسابات للتحقق
من أن مجموعها يساوي مصفوفة الوحدة. لكن طريقة أخرى لرؤية ذلك هي التفكير في التناظر: إذا حسبنا متوسط هذه الحالات الأربع
معاً نحصل على الحالة المختلطة تماماً الموجودة في مركز كرة Bloch. لكن بما أننا نقسم
كل واحدة على اثنين بدلاً من أربعة نحصل على ضعف الحالة المختلطة تماماً وهي مصفوفة الوحدة. لن أقول المزيد عن
هذا القياس الآن إلا أنه ليس قياساً إسقاطياً لكنه مثال جميل و
سنراه يظهر مرة أخرى لاحقاً في الدرس. طريقة أخرى لوصف القياسات العامة هي كقنوات كما سنناقش
الآن. الفكرة هنا هي أن الحالات الاحتمالية الكلاسيكية يمكن تمثيلها بمصفوفات كثافة قطرية ولذلك
بما أن نتائج القياس كلاسيكية يمكننا التفكير في القياسات كقنوات حيث المخرج هو دائماً مصفوفة كثافة قطرية
تصف نتيجة القياس. فلنلقِ نظرة أكثر تفصيلاً على هذا. إذا فكرنا
بشكل مجرد في قياس عام يمكننا وصف ذلك القياس كقناة phi. نظام الإدخال للقناة هو
أي نظام X يُقاس ونظام الإخراج هو نظام Y حالاته الكلاسيكية تتوافق مع
نتائج القياس والتي نأخذها كالأعداد الصحيحة من 0 إلى n ناقص واحد لعدد صحيح موجب
M. وبما أن نتائج القياس كلاسيكية نشترط أنه لكل مصفوفة كثافة إدخال rho للنظام
X يجب أن يكون الإخراج phi من rho مصفوفة كثافة قطرية. مثلاً إذا فكرنا في
قياس أساس معياري لـ qubit وفكرنا في ذلك القياس كقناة يمكننا التعبير عنه كما لدينا هنا على الشاشة.
إذا كانت مصفوفة الكثافة المدخلة هي rho فسنحصل على النتيجة صفر باحتمال يساوي bra 0 rho ket 0
وسنحصل على النتيجة واحد باحتمال bra 1 rho ket 1. وإذا عبّرنا عن هذه النتائج الكلاسيكية
للقياس كمصفوفات كثافة سنحصل على هذا التعبير للقناة المقابلة. ويتبين
أنها ليست سوى قناة إزالة الطور الكامل. وهذا يتسق مع فكرة أن قناة إزالة الطور
الكامل تمثل شكلاً متطرفاً من فقدان الترابط والذي يمكن أن يعني أشياء مختلفة لكن عندما أستخدم هذا المصطلح أقصد
ميل الحالات الكمية لأن تصبح كلاسيكية لأن البيئة المحيطة بأي نظام نتحدث
عنه تراقب بمعنى ما أو بعبارة أخرى تقيس.
إذن نتائج القياس يمكن وصفها كقنوات كما شرحت للتو لكن هذا ليس مجرد إمكانية بل هو
توصيف للقياسات العامة. وما أعنيه بذلك هو التالي: بالطبع هناك قنوات
لا تمثل قياسات لأن المخرج قد لا يكون دائماً مصفوفة كثافة قطرية. لكن إذا كان
الأمر كذلك أن مخرج قناة ما هو دائماً مصفوفة كثافة قطرية بغض النظر عن حالة الإدخال rho التي نختارها فمن الممكن بالضرورة
التعبير عن تلك القناة بالصيغة الموضحة على الشاشة لاختيار ما من قياس أي مجموعة من
المصفوفات شبه الموجبة المحددة التي مجموعها يساوي مصفوفة الوحدة. وهذا جيد لأسباب متعددة منها أنه
يخبرنا أساساً أن تعريفنا للقياسات كمجموعات من المصفوفات لا يفوته
شيء. طريقة أخرى لقول ذلك هي أن هذه الطريقة في التفكير بالقياسات كقنوات هي عملياتية
أو بديهية ربما بمعنى أنها تلتقط ما يجب أن يكون عليه القياس وهو عملية فيزيائية
تحوّل المعلومات الكمية إلى معلومات كلاسيكية. ويتبين أنها مكافئة تماماً لوصفنا الأول
للقياسات وهو جبري بحت. لن أستعرض برهان التكافؤ في هذا الفيديو لكنه
ليس صعباً وإذا كنت مهتماً يمكنك إيجاد البرهان في المادة المكتوبة للدرس المرتبطة في وصف الفيديو.
ناقشنا ما يحدث عند إجراء قياس عام على نظام في حالة معينة
على الأقل في حالة القياسات المدمرة. بعد ذلك سنتحدث عن القياسات الجزئية بمعنى أن
جزءاً واحداً فقط من نظام مركب يُقاس. لنكون دقيقين لنفترض أن لدينا زوجاً من الأنظمة XZ
معاً في حالة موصوفة بمصفوفة كثافة rho ويُجرى قياس موصوف بمجموعة من المصفوفات شبه الموجبة المحددة التي مجموعها يساوي
مصفوفة الوحدة على النظام X وحده. وبشكل طبيعي ينتج عن هذا
نتيجة قياس وبما أننا نتحدث عن قياسات مدمرة يمكننا تخيل أن عملية القياس تدمر النظام
X. لكن لا يزال لدينا النظام Z لنقلق بشأنه ونحتاج لفهم كيف يؤثر قياس X على
حالة Z. أولاً لنتحدث عن احتمالات
النتائج. بما أننا نتحدث عن قياس للنظام X وحده فإن احتمالات ظهور نتائج
مختلفة يمكن أن تعتمد فقط على حالة X بمفرده أي أنها يمكن أن تعتمد فقط على
الحالة المختزلة لـ X. بشكل خاص احتمال ظهور نتيجة معينة a يُعطى بنفس
الصيغة السابقة وهي أثر PA مضروباً في الحالة المختزلة لـ X والتي نرمز لها بـ rho
sub X. الحالة rho sub X تُحصل من rho بأخذ الأثر الجزئي على Z فيمكننا إجراء هذا
الاستبدال. ورغم أنه قد لا يكون واضحاً فوراً إلا أن التعبير الذي نحصل عليه يمكن كتابته بديلاً كما هو
موضح على الشاشة. إنه أثر PA الجداء التنسوري مع مصفوفة الوحدة على النظام Z مضروباً في
rho. هذه مساواة تستحق بالتأكيد أخذ بعض الوقت للتحقق منها. إنها بديهية فنحن لا نفعل
شيئاً على الإطلاق لـ Z لذا من المنطقي أن تظهر مصفوفة الوحدة على Z بهذا الشكل. لكن يمكن أيضاً التحقق منها
جبرياً وسأترك ذلك لكم مع اقتراح بأن تنظروا أولاً في حالة أن rho هي جداء تنسوري لمصفوفتين ثم
استخدام الخطية للاستنتاج أنها تعمل لكل rho. وسأقول أيضاً أن هذا لا يعتمد على كون PA
شبه موجبة المحددة أو أن rho مصفوفة كثافة. هذه مساواة تعمل لأي اختيار من
المصفوفات بدلاً من PA و rho طالما أن أبعادها صحيحة ليكون التعبير
ذا معنى. والآن لنرَ كيف تتأثر حالة Z بالقياس. والنهج الطبيعي في
رأيي هو التفكير في القياس كقناة. هنا القناة التي نربطها بقياسنا ونحن
نفكر في هذا كقناة من النظام X إلى نظام جديد Y حالاته الكلاسيكية تتوافق مع نتائج القياس. ففي هذه الصيغة
sigma تمثل حالة للنظام X وحده. إذا طبقنا هذه القناة على
النظام X بينما الزوج XZ في الحالة rho فسنحصل على مصفوفة الكثافة الموجودة هنا. مرة أخرى
خذ ما تحتاجه من وقت للتحقق من هذا واقتراحي مرة أخرى هو النظر أولاً في حالة أن rho جداء تنسوري
لمصفوفتين ثم استخدام الخطية. الآن رأينا هذا النوع من الحالات
حيث النظام الأول كلاسيكي والنظام الثاني كمي كمثال في درس مصفوفة
الكثافة. كل a يحدث باحتمال ما وهذا هو أثر العامل التنسوري الثاني. فيمكنك التفكير
في هذه العوامل التنسورية الثانية كمصفوفات كثافة مضروبة في احتمالات. فللحصول على حالة
Z المشروطة بالحصول على نتيجة قياس معينة a نقسم ببساطة على الاحتمال أو بعبارة أخرى
نقوم بتنظيم العامل التنسوري الثاني بقسمته على أثره. فباختصار إذا أجرينا
قياساً على X بينما الزوج XZ في الحالة rho فهذا ما يحدث. أولاً كل نتيجة a تظهر
باحتمال يساوي أثر PA الجداء التنسوري مع مصفوفة الوحدة مضروباً في rho. وثانياً بشرط الحصول على
نتيجة قياس معينة a فإن حالة Z تُعطى بالتعبير الموضح على الشاشة وهو ما نحصل عليه
بتنظيم المصفوفة التي رأيناها قبل لحظة. وهذا نفس الشيء كقسمة المصفوفة على احتمال
ظهور a. يجب أن أذكر أن هذا منطقي فقط إذا كان الاحتمال غير صفري لأننا بخلاف ذلك
نقسم على صفر. لكن هذا مقبول لأننا لا نحتاج أن نقلق بشأن أشياء لا تحدث. في هذا الجزء من
الدرس سنناقش نظرية بسيطة لكن أساسية عن القياسات تُعرف بنظرية Naimark.
باختصار ما تقوله هو أن أي قياس يمكن تنفيذه كما يوحي الشكل على الشاشة.
بالكلمات: قياس عام معين على نظام X يمكن تنفيذه بالطريقة التالية.
نُدخل أولاً نظام عمل مهيأ Y حالاته الكلاسيكية هي نتائج القياس الممكنة والتي نفترض أنها
مرقمة من 0 إلى n ناقص واحد. ثم تُجرى عملية وحدوية U على الزوج
YX ثم يُجرى قياس أساس معياري على Y. فكل شيء أساساً محدد
هنا باستثناء اختيار U. وما تقوله النظرية هو أنه من الممكن فعلاً اختيار هذه العملية الوحدوية
U بحيث تتوافق احتمالات النتائج المختلفة دائماً مع القياس العام المعطى.
الآن لنرَ كيف تُبرهن نظرية Naimark وهي ليست صعبة. نحتاج فقط لاختيار جيد
للعملية الوحدوية U والتحقق من أنها تعمل. لكن أولاً نحتاج حقيقة أساسية
من نظرية المصفوفات وهي أنه لأي مصفوفة شبه موجبة المحددة P توجد دائماً مصفوفة شبه موجبة المحددة
فريدة Q بحيث Q تربيع يساوي P. بشكل عام قد تكون هناك مصفوفات كثيرة تربيعها يعطينا P لكن
هناك دائماً واحدة فقط منها شبه موجبة المحددة. الترميز الذي نستخدمه لهذه المصفوفة هو الجذر التربيعي
لـ P وهذا أيضاً ما نسميها. إذا أردت حساب الجذر التربيعي لـ P لمصفوفة شبه موجبة
المحددة P بالمناسبة يمكنك فعل ذلك بحساب التحليل الطيفي لـ P أولاً ثم
استبدال كل قيمة ذاتية بجذرها التربيعي وترك المتجهات الذاتية كما هي. القيم الذاتية كلها غير
سالبة فهذا منطقي ومن السهل رؤية أن المصفوفة الناتجة شبه موجبة المحددة فعلاً
وتربيعها يساوي P. أما كونها فريدة فهذا أمر مختلف. ليس من الصعب
إثبات ذلك باستخدام بعض الحقائق الأساسية عن المصفوفات لكنه يخرج عن موضوع الدرس وسنأخذ ذلك الجزء
كمعطى. والآن بهذا المفهوم في متناول اليد من السهل جداً تحديد
عملية وحدوية U تعمل. أي مصفوفة وحدوية تطابق النمط الموضح على الشاشة ستعمل في الحقيقة.
أول n عمود بافتراض أن X له n حالة كلاسيكية كما سبق تُحصل بتكديس الجذور التربيعية
لمصفوفات القياس فوق بعضها. والأعمدة المتبقية يمكن أن تكون أي شيء
نريده. لا يُحدث أي فرق طالما أن المصفوفة الكلية وحدوية.
وبالمناسبة إذا لاحظت تشابهاً مع العلاقة بين تمثيلات Kraus و Stinespring للقنوات فهذا ليس مصادفة و
في الحقيقة ما لدينا هنا هو أساساً حالة خاصة من ذلك حيث مصفوفات Kraus كلها تصادف أنها شبه موجبة
المحددة. فهناك شيئان نحتاج للتحقق منهما. الأول هو أن هذا الاختيار لـ U يعمل فعلاً و
الثاني هو أنه من الممكن اختيار الأعمدة غير المحددة بطريقة تجعل U وحدوية. فلنبدأ بالأول.
هنا الحالة التي نبدأ بها. النظام السفلي Y مهيأ في حالة الصفر بينما النظام العلوي
يبدأ في الحالة rho ثم نُجري U مما يعني أننا نقرن بـ
U. يمكننا كتابة كل هذا بمصفوفات كتلية كما هو موضح على الشاشة. لدينا U على اليسار و U المرافقة على
اليمين و ket 0 bra 0 الجداء التنسوري مع rho في المنتصف والتي تأخذ الشكل الموجود هنا حيث لدينا rho في
الزاوية العلوية اليسرى وأصفار في كل مكان آخر. وإذا فكرت في هذا الجداء للحظة يتضح أن
العناصر غير المحددة في U لا تهم على الإطلاق لأنها دائماً تُضرب بعناصر صفرية من هذه
المصفوفة في المنتصف. وإذا أجرينا الضرب نحصل على هذه
المصفوفة الموضحة هنا كمصفوفة كتلية. أو بديلاً يمكننا التعبير عنها باستخدام ترميز Dirac
هكذا. هذا في الحقيقة هو الشكل الأكثر ملاءمة لنا فلنركز على هذا
التعبير ومن أجل الراحة لنسمِّ هذه المصفوفة وهي مصفوفة كثافة بالاسم
sigma. الخطوة الأخيرة هي قياس الأساس المعياري على Y فلنحسب الحالة المختزلة في Y و
هذا سهل بالنظر إلى التعبير الذي لدينا. ببساطة نأخذ الأثر الجزئي على X الذي يتوافق مع العامل التنسوري
الثاني. فاحتمال ظهور أي نتيجة معينة a هو العنصر القطري المقابل لـ a. يمكننا كتابة
ذلك هكذا ويساوي أثر الجذر التربيعي لـ PA ضرب rho ضرب الجذر
التربيعي لـ PA. وبالخاصية الدورية للأثر نحصل على أثر PA ضرب rho
وهو ما كنا نأمل فيه. فاحتمالات ظهور النتائج المختلفة صحيحة وتتوافق دائماً
مع القياس الأصلي الذي بدأنا به. الشيء الثاني الذي نحتاج للتحقق منه
هو أنه من الممكن ملء الأعمدة غير المحددة في U بطريقة تجعلها
وحدوية. هذا ينتج من حقيقة أن أول n أعمدة وهي التي تتكون من الجذور التربيعية لمصفوفات القياس
هي متعامدة معيارية ويمكن التحقق من ذلك مباشرة. التفاصيل ذات الصلة هنا
على الشاشة. أوقف الفيديو وخذ بضع لحظات للتفكير في ذلك إذا أردت. لكن كما اقترحت سابقاً
هذه في الحقيقة حالة خاصة من شيء واجهناه في الدرس السابق وهذا هو
البرهان. حتى الآن في الدرس أبقينا تركيزنا على القياسات المدمرة بمعنى أنه لا يوجد تحديد
للحالة الكمية بعد القياس للنظام الذي قيس. أما في القياس غير المدمر من ناحية أخرى فلا يوجد
فقط نتيجة قياس كلاسيكية بل أيضاً حالة كمية بعد القياس للنظام الذي قيس. وكما
سنرى هناك علاقة طبيعية بنظرية Naimark. هناك في الحقيقة طرق مختلفة لصياغة القياسات غير المدمرة
بالمصطلحات الرياضية لكننا سنبدأ بصياغة تأتي أساساً مباشرة من نظرية Naimark.
لنأخذ قياساً عاماً أي مدمراً موصوفاً بمجموعة من المصفوفات شبه الموجبة المحددة
P0 إلى PN ناقص واحد التي مجموعها يساوي مصفوفة الوحدة. يمكننا عندئذ تحويل هذا
القياس إلى قياس غير مدمر ببساطة عبر النظر في تنفيذ هذا القياس الذي ناقشناه في سياق نظرية Naimark.
نُدخل نظاماً جديداً Y ونتفاعل معه مع X عبر عملية وحدوية U ثم نُجري قياس أساس
معياري على Y. فالنظام X لا يزال موجوداً ويمكننا النظر في
حالته. وبناءً على التحليل الذي أجريناه يمكننا تحديد أن حالة X بعد القياس المشروطة
بالحصول على نتيجة قياس معينة a تُعطى بمصفوفة كثافة تبدو
هكذا. بالكلمات نقرن بالجذر التربيعي لمصفوفة القياس المقابلة ثم
ننظم. طريقة أخرى لصياغة القياسات غير المدمرة وهي أعم هي بدلالة مصفوفات Kraus
للقنوات. وهذا هو تعريف القياسات الذي ستجده في كتاب Nielsen و
Chuang الشهير مثلاً. افترض أن M0 إلى M M ناقص واحد مصفوفات مربعة تحقق
المعادلة الموضحة على الشاشة أي أنه يمكننا التفكير في هذه المصفوفات كمصفوفات Kraus تصف
قناة. في الحقيقة هذه المصفوفات تصف قناة لكنها تصف أيضاً قياساً غير مدمر
والطريقة التي يعمل بها عند قياس نظام في حالة معينة rho هي أولاً احتمالات النتائج
تُعطى بالمعادلة الموضحة على الشاشة. كل نتيجة تظهر باحتمال يساوي أثر Ma ضرب
rho ضرب Ma المرافقة. وبشرط ظهور النتيجة a فإن حالة النظام المقاس
تبدو هكذا. القياسات غير المدمرة من هذا النوع يمكن تنفيذها بطريقة
مشابهة لما كان لدينا في نظرية Naimark وسأترك لكم التفكير في ذلك إذا
أردتم. من الممكن تعميم مفهوم القياس غير المدمر أكثر من هذا. مثلاً
هناك مفهوم ما يُسمى الأداة الكمية والذي يكون أحياناً مفيداً جداً لكنني لن أتناوله في هذا
الفيديو. في الجزء الأخير من الدرس سأناقش باختصار مهمتين مرتبطتين بالقياسات: تمييز الحالة الكمية وتصوير الحالة الكمية
المقطعي. هناك الكثير ليُقال عن كلا المفهومين ونحن حقاً سنخدش
السطح فقط. فلنبدأ بتوضيح ماذا تعني هذه المصطلحات وكيف تختلف.
أولاً تمييز الحالة الكمية. الفكرة هنا هي أن لدينا مجموعة معروفة من الحالات الكمية
لنظام ما مع احتمالات مرتبطة بهذه الحالات. لنكون دقيقين لنفترض
أن rho 0 إلى rho M ناقص واحد مصفوفات كثافة تمثل حالات كمية ممكنة لنظام X و p0
إلى pN ناقص واحد احتمالات مرتبطة بهذه الحالات. فإذا جمعنا الاحتمالات في متجه
واحد نحصل على متجه احتمالي. طريقة مختصرة لقول هذا بالمناسبة هي أن لدينا مجموعة من الحالات
الكمية. والآن طريقة مجردة للتفكير في تمييز الحالة الكمية كمهمة أو مسألة
هي أن عدداً بين 0 و N ناقص واحد يُختار عشوائياً وفقاً للاحتمالات. ثم يُحضّر النظام X
في الحالة المقابلة للعدد المختار عشوائياً والهدف هو تحديد عن طريق
قياس X أي عدد تم اختياره. فلدينا عدد محدود من
البدائل مع توزيع مسبق والهدف هو تحديد أي بديل حدث فعلاً. لبعض اختيارات الحالات و
الاحتمالات قد يكون هذا سهلاً ولبعضها الآخر قد لا يكون ممكناً بدون بعض فرص الخطأ.
وهناك أسئلة محددة مختلفة يمكننا طرحها مثل ما هو الحد الأدنى لاحتمال الخطأ
وكيف يبدو القياس الذي يحقق هذا الحد الأدنى لاحتمال الخطأ. تصوير الحالة الكمية المقطعي من
ناحية أخرى مختلف. هنا لدينا حالة كمية مجهولة لنظام ما فلا يوجد
عادةً توزيع مسبق أو أي معلومات عن بدائل ممكنة. هذه المرة لكن ليست نسخة واحدة من الحالة المتاحة
بل نسخ مستقلة كثيرة متاحة. بمعنى أنه لعدد ربما كبير
n لدينا n نظام متطابق X1 إلى Xn كل منها محضّر بشكل مستقل في الحالة
rho. وهذه المرة الهدف هو إيجاد تقريب لهذه الحالة الكمية المجهولة كمصفوفة كثافة عن طريق قياس
الأنظمة. فباختصار في تمييز الحالة الكمية لدينا نسخة واحدة من
الحالة ونحاول التمييز بين عدد محدود من البدائل المعروفة. وفي تصوير الحالة الكمية المقطعي لدينا نسخ مستقلة كثيرة
من حالة كمية مجهولة والهدف هو إيجاد وصف لتلك الحالة أو على الأقل تقريب جيد
لها. تمييز الحالة الكمية مثير للاهتمام لأنه يجرد نوعاً من المواقف التي تنشأ عادةً في
الحوسبة والتشفير مثلاً حيث حدث بديل واحد من مجموعة محدودة من الاحتمالات ونحن أو شخص آخر يحاول
معرفة أيها كان عن طريق قياس نظام كمي. أبسط حالة غير بديهية هي
عندما يكون هناك بديلان فقط أي M يساوي اثنين فالمهمة هي التمييز بين زوج
من الحالات. هذه الحالة تتبين أنها مسألة محلولة تماماً بافتراض أن الهدف هو تقليل
فرصة التمييز الخاطئ. هناك اختيار أمثل للقياس ويُسمى عادةً
قياس Helstrom. وهو قياس إسقاطي في الحقيقة ويمكن وصفه
كالتالي. أولاً ننظر في الفرق الموزون بين البديلين أي p0 ضرب rho 0 ناقص p1 ضرب rho 1.
فنحن نضرب احتمال سحب كل من هاتين الحالتين في الحالة نفسها ونأخذ
الفرق. هذه مصفوفة هرمتية لأنها تساوي المرافق المنقول لنفسها فلها تحليل طيفي
ونعلم بشكل خاص أن القيم الذاتية كلها أعداد حقيقية. فلنفترض أن لدينا
تحليلاً طيفياً مكتوباً بالشكل الموضح على الشاشة. ما نفعله بعد ذلك هو تجميع
القيم الذاتية في مجموعتين حيث القيم الذاتية الموجبة في مجموعة والسالبة في
الأخرى. لنكون دقيقين لنأخذ S0 كمجموعة كل الفهارس k التي القيمة الذاتية المقابلة Lambda k فيها
غير سالبة و S1 الفهارس المتبقية وهي المقابلة لقيم ذاتية سالبة.
لا يهم في الحقيقة أي مجموعة تحتوي على الفهارس المقابلة لقيم ذاتية صفرية. هنا نختار
اختياراً عشوائياً بتضمينها في S0 لكن لن يُحدث أي فرق لو ضُمّن بعضها أو كلها في S1 بدلاً من ذلك. كل ما يهم حقاً هو
أننا نفصل بين القيم الذاتية الموجبة والسالبة. وأخيراً نعرّف إسقاطين Pi
0 و Pi 1 كما هو موضح على الشاشة. بالكلمات Pi 0 هو الإسقاط على الفضاء الجزئي
المولّد بالمتجهات الذاتية المقابلة لقيم ذاتية غير سالبة و Pi 1 هو الإسقاط على الفضاء
المولّد بالمتجهات الذاتية المقابلة لقيم ذاتية سالبة. هذه إسقاطات فعلاً و
إذا جمعناها معاً نحصل على مصفوفة الوحدة لأن المتجهات الذاتية S0 إلى SN ناقص واحد تشكل
أساساً متعامداً معيارياً. إذا أُجري هذا القياس في الوضع المعني بمعنى أن
الحالة المقاسة هي rho 0 باحتمال p0 و rho 1 باحتمال p1 فيتبين أن
احتمال التعرف الصحيح له صيغة بسيطة جداً بدلالة القيم الذاتية Lambda 0 إلى Lambda n ناقص
واحد. لن أستعرض تفاصيل الحساب في هذا الفيديو. يمكنك الرجوع للمحتوى المكتوب المرتبط في وصف الفيديو إذا كنت
مهتماً أو حاول أن تقنع نفسك بأن هذه الصيغة صحيحة فعلاً. يمكننا أيضاً التعبير عن هذا
الاحتمال باستخدام نظيم مصفوفات يُسمى عادةً نظيم الأثر. ترميزه مشابه لنظيم الإقليدي للمتجهات
إلا أن لدينا دليلاً سفلياً واحد للإشارة إلى أنه نظيم الأثر. نظيم الأثر مهم جداً و
شائع جداً في الحوسبة الكمية لكنني لن أقول الكثير عنه في هذا الدرس. إحدى طرق
تعريفه للمصفوفات الهرمتية هي أنه مجموع القيم المطلقة للقيم الذاتية. فيمكنك التفكير
في هذه المساواة الثانية كنتيجة مباشرة لذلك التعريف. نظيم الأثر يمكن أيضاً
تعريفه بطرق أخرى أعم وسنواجه نظيم الأثر مرة أخرى في الدرس القادم. هذا في الحقيقة
أفضل ما يمكنك فعله. هذا القياس أمثل بافتراض أن هدفك هو تعظيم فرصة التخمين
الصحيح. هذه الحقيقة تُسمى أحياناً نظرية Helstrom-Holevo وتُسمى أحياناً فقط نظرية
Helstrom. فلا يمكنك التفوق على هذا القياس من حيث احتمال الصحة وهو جميل لأن
هناك وصفة بسيطة للقياس نفسه وصيغة دقيقة لاحتمال الصحة بدلالة نظيم
الأثر. نظيم الأثر يُستخدم غالباً كطريقة لقياس الفرق الملحوظ بين مصفوفات الكثافة
لهذا السبب بالذات. وعندما يتحدث الناس عن مسافة الأثر بين الحالات فعادةً يقصدون
نصف نظيم الأثر للفرق بين مصفوفتي الكثافة وهو ما يقابل هنا الحالة التي يكون فيها p0 و p1 كلاهما نصف وهي
حالة طبيعية للنظر فيها. تمييز الحالة الكمية لحالتين يُحل بشكل أمثل بواسطة
قياس Helstrom الذي لدينا له وصفة بسيطة وصيغة بسيطة لاحتمال
الصحة. فماذا يحدث عندما نريد التمييز بين ثلاث حالات أو أكثر؟ في هذه الحالة لا نملك
صيغة عامة للاختيار الأمثل للقياس أو تعبيراً بسيطاً لأقصى احتمال
صحة. لكن من الممكن إيجاد تقريب جيد لقياس أمثل بمساعدة الحاسوب
وبشكل خاص يمكن ذلك باستخدام تقنية تحسين رائعة وقوية تُعرف بالبرمجة شبه المحددة. لكنه ليس
شيئاً يمكنك تنفيذه عملياً بقلم وورقة مثلاً. من ناحية أخرى إذا أعطاك أحد
وصفاً لقياس وادعى أن هذا القياس أمثل لمهمة تمييز حالة كمية فمن
السهل جداً التحقق من صحة أو خطأ ذلك الادعاء. ويمكن ذلك باستخدام ما يُسمى شروط Holevo-Yuen-
Kennedy-Lax. لن أشرح ماهيتها في هذا الفيديو لكنها شروط بسيطة ومن الرائع
أن هذا ممكن. هنا مثال يرتبط بالحالات رباعية الأوجه
التي رأيناها سابقاً في الدرس. افترض أننا نُعطى إحدى هذه الحالات الأربع مختارة عشوائياً
باحتمال ربع لكل واحدة وهدفنا تحديد أي حالة أُعطينا. قد لا يكون مفاجئاً لكن
أفضل اختيار يمكنك فعله للقياس هو القياس رباعي الأوجه. لا يمكنك دائماً فعل
شيء كهذا لمجموعة عشوائية من الحالات النقية لكن بسبب التناظرات هنا هذا يعمل
ونحصل فعلاً على قياس صالح. ومن خلال شروط Holevo-Yuen-Kennedy-Lax التي ذكرتها
قبل قليل يتبين أنه من السهل جداً إثبات أن هذا فعلاً اختيار أمثل
للقياس. تحديداً ما يحدث هنا هو أن القياس يكون صحيحاً دائماً باحتمال نصف وهو ليس
سيئاً لأن هناك أربعة بدائل فاحتمال التخمين الصحيح هو ضعف التخمين العشوائي و
هذا هو أفضل ما يمكنك فعله لهذه الحالات. الآن سأقول المزيد قليلاً عن تصوير الحالة الكمية المقطعي
حيث لدينا نسخ مستقلة كثيرة من حالة كمية مجهولة والهدف هو إيجاد تقريب لمصفوفة الكثافة التي تصف
تلك الحالة. هناك في الحقيقة عدة متغيرات مختلفة لهذه المسألة تعتمد على افتراضاتك و
بشكل خاص على أنواع القياسات المسموح بها. مثلاً يمكننا أن نشترط أن كل نظام يُقاس منفرداً و
تُجمع النتائج بطريقة ما للوصول إلى وصف لمصفوفة الكثافة. أو يمكننا السماح بقياس كل
الأنظمة معاً كنظام مركب واحد وهو أفضل بكثير نظرياً لكنه أيضاً أكثر
تطلباً من الناحية التقنية. بالإضافة إلى الخيارات المتعلقة بالقياسات هناك
أيضاً اعتبار مهم وهو كيفية إعادة بناء وصف لمصفوفة الكثافة من أي بيانات
تحصل عليها من القياسات. لن أدخل في التفاصيل ونقطتي ببساطة هي الإشارة
إلى أن تصوير الحالة الكمية المقطعي هو حقاً مفهوم شامل له متغيرات كثيرة مختلفة وليس
إجراءً واحداً. كان هناك الكثير من الأبحاث في هذه المسألة بما في ذلك بعض النتائج
الاختراقية الحديثة نسبياً التي تربط عدد النسخ n بدقة التقريب الذي يمكن الحصول عليه وتستمر كمجال
بحثي مثير ونشط. لنختم الدرس لنلقِ نظرة على تصوير الحالة الكمية المقطعي
لـ qubit وكيف يمكننا القيام به. فلنفترض أن rho مصفوفة كثافة تمثل حالة
qubit واحد و X1 إلى Xn هي qubit كلها حُضّرت بشكل مستقل في الحالة rho ومن
أجل هذا النقاش لنفترض أن n كبير. ما يمكننا فعله هو تقسيم
الأنظمة إلى ثلاث مجموعات متساوية تقريباً وللمجموعة الأولى نُجري قياساً بالنسبة لأساس plus
minus. لكل نتيجة مقابلة لـ plus نسجل زائد واحد ولكل
نتيجة مقابلة لـ minus نسجل ناقص واحد. طريقة أكثر اختصاراً لوصف هذا القياس
هي أنه قياس Pauli X لأن حالتي plus و minus هما متجهان ذاتيان لمصفوفة Pauli X و
القيم الذاتية المقابلة هي زائد واحد وناقص واحد. وفي الحقيقة هذه أيضاً طريقة أكثر شيوعاً لوصفه و
فعلاً القيمة المتوقعة للدرجة تساوي أثر sigma x ضرب rho. الآن لا نتعلم بالضرورة ما
هذه القيمة المتوقعة لكن إذا حسبنا متوسط الدرجات التي نحصل عليها عبر تجارب كثيرة جداً فمن المرجح أن نحصل على
تقريب جيد لهذه القيمة المتوقعة بقانون الأعداد الكبيرة. وهناك حدود إحصائية معروفة يمكننا استخدامها
إذا أردنا أن نكون أكثر كمياً بشأن هذا التصريح. نفعل شيئاً مماثلاً مع sigma y على الثلث الثاني من
الأنظمة. الشيء الوحيد الذي يتغير هنا هو أننا نستخدم حالتي plus i و minus i وهما متجهان ذاتيان لـ sigma
Y. وبالمثل لـ sigma Z التي متجهات الأساس المعياري هي متجهاتها
الذاتية. وأخيراً يمكننا استخدام الصيغة الموضحة على الشاشة التي تخبرنا ما يجب أن تكون عليه المعاملات
إذا كُتبت rho كتركيب خطي لمصفوفات Pauli. وباستبدال تقريباتنا لهذه المعاملات
وربما تعديلها قليلاً للتأكد من أننا نحصل على مصفوفة شبه موجبة المحددة نحصل على تقريب
لـ rho. بالطبع هناك تفاصيل لم أتطرق إليها مثل دقة التقريب ودرجة
الثقة التي يمكننا أن نأمل فيها لكن نأمل أن يعطيكم هذا فكرة أساسية عن إحدى طرق إجراء التصوير المقطعي على
qubit. من الممكن أيضاً إجراء تصوير مقطعي لـ qubit باستخدام القياس رباعي الأوجه وفي الحقيقة هذا يتبين
أنه بسيط وأنيق جداً على الأقل من الناحية الرياضية. ما يمكننا فعله هو إجراء
هذا القياس الوحيد فقط على كل النسخ المستقلة من حالتنا الكمية المجهولة وباستخدام
الصيغة الرائعة الموضحة هنا يمكننا الوصول إلى تقريب لحالتنا عن طريق تقدير أثر PK ضرب
rho لكل K بنسبة المرات التي تظهر فيها نتيجة القياس المقابلة. مرة أخرى هذا يعمل فقط بسبب
التناظرات المثالية بين هذه الحالات الأربع. وهناك في الحقيقة مسائل مفتوحة رائعة تتعلق بتعميمات
هذا النهج لأنظمة أكبر. وهذا مكان جيد لإنهاء الدرس. شكراً لكم على المشاهدة و
أتمنى أن تنضموا إليّ في الدرس القادم الذي يتناول التنقيات والإخلاص. إلى اللقاء.